yes I cannot get inside miraculous
several reasons one is that headman
boasts had commissioned me to explore
the miraculous to think that the Dwemer
of several reasons one is that headman
boasts a commission an excellent
suggestion
I believe this automaton can wear the
focusing crystals in hand I can complete
this control rod and safely reactivate
the automaton summon a race of none can
seifish dim the gleam of avarice I see
in your eyes
every assemble despite Abaddon splendid
now I just let's see here it works I
knew it would of course into the tunnel
you go now to get that door open
at long last this sock come we'll talk
about next move inside as you see head
manbo sex trust in mice
despite the age of these ruins I suspect
the usual defenses are in place oh I
said this control rod will keep our new
excellent work but sock breeds again as
you see we are not the first to enter
good self-knowledge is the greatest
treasure an easy task those earlier
explorers there may be more constructs
wait
so the schematics were here I doubt they
escaped
these writings could prove crucial to
understanding the schematics
[Music]
ah the schematics are mine at I hear
Kalinin I must get the schematics to my
workshop join me if you wish to return
to town